>>As we all know one of the things that we
really enjoy working with
over here at Google are very large data sets,
very complex problems.
You know, lots and lots of bits coming through.
And nowhere is that more true than in the
astronomy world, where each night on a telescope
run, we have terabytes and gigabytes of data
coming through.
And all that has to be sorted, you know, the
signal-to-noise ratio adjusted and processed.
It's a really large and complex issue.
And that's why we really enjoy working with
our friends at NASA and throughout the astronomy
community. And so today we're very pleased
to be joined by our friends from the Keck
Observatory down in sunny Hawaii.
So I can definitely say aloha to that. I was
really pleased to get my lei today.
I've never been to Hawaii but now I really
have to go even more
seriously than before.
So we're pleased to be joined by a Dr. Taft
Armandroff.
He is the director of the Observatory.
And he's going to talk to us today about some
of the new innovations that are going on at
Keck,
and how, you know, we work those large data
sets.
And really just make astronomy even more accessible
to the general public.
So just want to give you some quick background
on Taft as well.
So he graduated from Wesleyan and earned his
graduate work in Yale, all in astronomy, of
course.
And he's authored over 41 refereed journals
and review, review papers. And his research
areas not only focus on managing these large
mass of telescopes from, you know, Arizona
to Hawaii and beyond.
But more specifically in dwarf and spheroidal
galaxies,
and stellar proportions and the Milky Way
galaxy and nearby
galaxies.
As well as globular clusters, the chemical
evolution of
galaxies and dark matter.
And so he joined Keck in 2006.
And he will be very pleased to show us the
latest innovations.
We'll have time for Q&A at the end and I'll
have a mike.
So without further ado, please join me in
welcoming Taft.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Thank you very much, Cliff.
It's an honor to be here at Google today.
And there's so much we have in common here
at the center of the information revolution.
Cliff did a great job talking about the complex
data sets and algorithms that I think both
of our organizations are really interested
in.
Information is an absolute key in astronomy.
And just as a small sample of what we have
in common,
we're all thrilled with Google Sky, for example.
That's a real tool both for our community,
and for the general public in learning more
about the universe.
So let me tell --
let me begin by telling you a little bit about
the Observatory.
These are the two telescopes, opening up for
another night of fabulous discoveries atop
Mauna Kea in Hawaii.
These are the two largest optical infrared
telescopes that are
steerable.
You know, that can point to different places
in the sky
that are in operation today.
So 10 meters, 400 inches across the primary
mirror.
Before they came online, the largest telescope
was the venerable 5 meter or 200-inch telescope
at Mount Palomar.
We have a very advanced suite of instrumentation
that sits behind the telescopes that produces
the data.
And we have an incredible site atop Mauna
Kea here.
It's a dormant volcano, of course.
14,000 feet elevation.
So only 60 percent of the atmosphere is above
us at 14,000 feet.
40 percent of the atmosphere is below us,
so that's that much less light to interfere
with the observations.
They're --
astronomers love data, so we've surveyed just
about every mountaintop on earth that could
be good
for astronomy,
and Mauna Kea has come out as number one.
The reasons for that are several, but let
me cite the two most important.
One the sky is incredibly dark in Hawaii Island.
You know, we're mostly surrounded by ocean.
We have a rural economy.
Population is very low.
We have a very progressive lighting ordinances
to keep the light
focused on the ground instead of shooting
up into the sky.
So we're working on incredibly faint objects.
And we cannot detect them against a bright
background, of course.
So that's one.
The other is that the air is just very stable
above Mauna Kea.
The air has been traveling across the Pacific
without running into other mountain ranges
or very heated up areas and causing it to
become turbulent.
So it's a very smooth-shaped volcano, so we
get a very smooth laminar flow of air.
And so that's the area that Mauna Kea is absolutely
exceptional of.
It's the mountain that has the lowest level
of turbulence in the
atmosphere above it on earth.
Here's a view of our telescopes.
This is the primary mirror.
This is the collecting area for photons coming
in from the universe. So you can think of
it this way:
Imagine you were a photon that had travelled
from a galaxy for ten billion years.
This is the view you'd see before you gave
yourself up for the
benefit of science.
The --
you can see we do everything we can to give
a clear path to the primary mirror.
And the primary isn't monolithic.
The traditional way to make telescopes was
to make one very large
mirror.
There's probably an analogy to computers here
for all you Googlers.
So the tradition was you make one very large
mirror.
And you have to make it thick enough so that
it's stable against gravity as you point it
at different places in the sky.
Well that --
you could only scale that so far because of
the thermal stresses.
When you cast the mirror, they would crack
as you made them larger and larger.
So the project scientist for the Observatory
when it was just getting
underway, Jerry Nelson, came up with this
concept,
that you could have 32 segments instead, 32
hexagonal segments.
And each of them would have its own active
control.
So they're --
the backs of them have a --
and the sides have a lot of censors on them.
They feed their positions back to computers.
And they're controlled very accurately.
We have to keep the surface of this mirror
within form to a 20th of the wavelength of
light that we detect.
So the shortest wavelengths of light that
we detect at the observatory about a third
of a micron.
So we have to keep that surface within speck
to a 60th of a micron.
So it's pretty incredible technology.
And it wouldn't be possible without distributed
computers and censors, which didn't really
exist before the Observatory came online in
1993. So you can see a person there to give
you a sense
of scale.
So the light is collected by this primary
mirror, it's
reflected back up to the secondary mirror
and concentrated.
And then it bounces off the tertiary mirror
right there into one of the
instruments.
The telescope is used for all areas of astronomy.
I'll give you a sampling of some of the science
that we're working on today.
Just a small sampling.
But we study everything from the moon if you
can believe it, to the farthest edges of the
universe.
13 billion, where light has been traveling
for 13 billion years today. And the sense
that we're kind of cosmic archeologists studying
galaxies as they existed long, long ago.
This is another view of the telescope so you
can again see the primary and the tertiary
but this is where the information is produced.
It's produced at the instruments and this
is our Deimos Spectrograph. It can produce
spectro of optical multi-object spectrograph
on the planet today.
It's about the size of a small car.
And it costs about $10 million and takes a
number of years to develop,
maybe, you know, 3 to 5 years to develop one
of these things from
concept to being -- to being implemented.
So what's our mission?
What do we do at the observatory?
How do we grade ourselves?
We have a broad mission.
World leadership in ground-based astronomy.
And what we specialize in are the following
technical areas.
One of them is triangular resolution astrophysics.
That's getting the finest spatial detailing
we can get in the sky.
As your telescopes get larger and larger,
once you correct for the finer and finer spatial
detail, higher angular resolution.
We do a lot of spectroscopy of the light.
So that's going beyond imaging, of course.
For every object that we study --
and you just need to collect a lot of light
to be able to slice and dice it into spectra
--
so having the world's largest telescope is
very enabling
in that.
And so we do spectra on faint objects.
We do very high precision spectroscopy on
brighter objects.
And we do highly multi-spectroscopy.
So being able to get spectra of, you know,
between ten and a thousand objects in a given
field of view.
We're a fairly small organization and a fairly
young organization.
So one of our missions is to exploit emerging
opportunities.
That ranges from time scales of --
during of night, if we find out that something
really
exciting has happened that night, like a gamma
ray burst has gone off
somewhere in the universe and has been detected
by a satellite,
we need to have the flexibility to get on
that and understand it.
But more broadly, we have to be very flexible
to emerging trends in astronomy.
Because of our size, because we're not a big
federal or international
bureaucracy, we can kind of turn ourselves
around to these problems and
be much more flexible.
And we're all about training the future leaders
in the field.
As you'll see in the next slide, we're very
closely associated with a number of universities.
And we have a lot of students and post-Docs
deeply involved in our research and becoming
the next generation of leaders.
This is our metric how we judge ourselves.
I imagine you have a number of metrics at
Google, but our metric is
publications in top refereed journals per
year.
So we first started publishing scientific
results in 1996.
And you can see, we're on a nice upslope in
terms of the number of scientific results
we publish each year.
The productivity of the telescopes keeps increasing.
We also measure by citations, of course, by
how influential each paper
is.
And so we lead the world in terms of ground-based
observatories
both in the number of papers published per
telescope, and in the impact
of our research, the numbers -- the numbers
of citations.
So our partners are very important to us.
Cal Tech and the University of California
are our founding partners.
I don't know if we have any UC or Cal Tech
alums in the crowd today? But each of them
control thirty-six and a half percent each
of the observing time in the telescope.
So they each have thirty-six and a half percent
of the opportunities to carry out experiments
in the telescopes.
NASA is a one-sixth partner, and receives
fourteen and a half of the observing time.
And the University of Hawaii, while not a
financial partner, they provide us access
to this very special site on top of Mauna
Kea
and thus gain access to twelve and a half
percent.
Private philanthropy is a major partner of
us.
The Keck Foundation gave us the capital, most
of the capital to build the Observatory to
start with.
And private philanthropy supports about 56
percent of our new development,
our building of new instruments,
and what we'll talk about as adaptive optics
systems.
And this gives us some freedom from the government
development cycle that can be a little slow.
So let me go from the budget of the Observatory
to the mass budget of the universe.
Just to give you a sense of what we're learning
about the universe and how quickly we're learning
things.
And perhaps how ignorant we were until very
recently.
One of the top results in the Observatory's
history was the discovery of dark energy by
using distant supernovae as standard candles
and beacons.
The universe, we all know, is expanding after
the Big Bang.
And astronomers were using a supernovae, so
exploding stars, with Keck Observatory.
And there are two groups.
One out of the Australian National University
led by Brian Schmidt. They had a number of
University of California colleagues. And another
led by Saul Perlmutter.
And what they were both trying to do with
Keck Observatory,
and these distant supernovae, is the peak
brightness of type 1A
supernovae had been calibrated so that could
be a standard candle.
So if you could find a type 1A supernovae
anywhere in the universe,
and you can get its spectrum, you would know
what its absolute brightness is.
So you measure its brightness with the telescope
and between the
two of those, that gives you the distance.
You also know its redshift.
And going back to way back to Edwin Hubble,
the further an object is
away, the higher the redshift.
It's much like in an expanding universe.
You can go to the analogy of raisins in a
loaf of raisin bread.
As the yeast is causing it to rise, and if
you're on any one raisin, you see all the
other raisins moving away from you.
And the further a raisin is from you, the
faster its expansion is seen to be,
because the total amount of dough along that
line of sight is larger. So the expansion
is larger.
So there's a linear relation between distance
and redshift.
Now if --
that's all left over from the Big Bang and
the exploding expansion of the universe.
So what these groups were trying to do was
to see if they could see the deceleration
in this expansion.
As all the galaxies in the universe feel their
collective gravity, that should, if it's strong
enough, it should appreciably slow down this
expansion.
Well, the shocking result that came out of
this was that they were
seeing an acceleration in the expansion instead
of a deceleration.
So something was driving this, this acceleration.
The universe wasn't slowing down.
The expansion was speeding up.
And this goes back to Einstein.
This result was the 1998 Science Magazine
result of the year, which it's very rare for
astronomy to be the Science Magazine
result of the year to start with.
But we were particularly thrilled to have
a result that had --
where the Keck telescopes had played such
an important role.
And Einstein, of course, had a term that he
eventually dismissed in his equations for
the behavior of the universe.
It was the cosmological constant that showed
a constant acceleration term.
So this has become dark energy.
And it's become one of the top problems in
theoretical physics today,
and in high energy physics,
to find the source of this dark energy that's
creating the accelerating expansion of the
universe.
So the mass budget of the universe now, the
best estimate is
it's 73 percent dark energy; 23 percent dark
matter; 3.6 percent as
you see, intergalactic gas that hasn't condensed
into galaxies or stars;
and only .4 percent stars and planets and
us.
So you don't feel terribly significant in
this, in this pie diagram. And it shows how
much we have to learn about the universe still,
and how we're very much on the frontier about
knowing what our universe is made of.
So what are we working on this year?
I went through all of the programs we're working
on this year to just find a few that are representative
of what's the cutting edge in astronomy today.
Oops. Did I?
Looks like I did something there.
We're back.
So one is what are the internal structures
of planets having Earth-mass to Saturn-mass
caused by the
various mixtures of rock, water, ice, hydrogen,
and helium gas?
So we're now able, as I'll say a little bit
more about, to explore solar planets to get
beyond our own solar system in terms of studying
planets.
And we're really -- the question originally
was are there planets around other stars?
That's a really challenging technical problem
that has now been solved. But now in the last
15 years, this field has just exploded and
we're talking about in --
investigating with the telescope, what really
makes the internal structures of planets different
when planetary systems form.
So I find that amazing.
The second question that's getting a lot of
attention this year is: How do galaxies lose
their interstellar medium and transition from
star-forming galaxies to galaxies that aren't
forming stars?
We call them quiescent.
So a galaxy is born with a lot of gas over
its lifetime.
It turns a lot of it into stars.
But galaxies lose their gas for various reasons
and stop forming stars. What are the dominant
physical processes that control this?
The third question that I'd picked out is
do the fundamental physics "constants" --
you all remember the various constants from
your physics classes in college or high school.
Do they vary over the lifetime of the universe?
And some clever astronomers have found a way
to look at the spectra of quasars and look
at and determine whether the fine structure
constants that we use all the time in atomic
physics,
whether those constants are truly constant.
Or whether -- whether the word constant is
a misnomer.
So it's a very exciting brew of science questions
that we get to look at each year.
Let me spend a little time on exoplanets because
this is an area that's just changed immensely
over the last decade.
But I want to go way back.
I want to go back to the late 1500s and quote
Giordano Bruno, who was a monk in that era.
He said, "There are countless suns and countless
earths all rotating around their suns in exactly
the same way as the seven planets of our system.
We see only the suns because they are the
largest bodies and are luminous, but their
planets remain invisible to us because they
are smaller and non-luminous.
The countless worlds in the universe are no
worse and no less inhabited
than our Earth."
And he really set the stage for what we're
doing today, but he did it based on pure thought.
He was completely right.
There are planets around other suns.
And we can't see them because they're not
emitting very much energy,
and they're so small compared to the stars
that they don't reflect much energy as seen
from earth.
I mean, they can easily be a million to ten
million times fainter than the star.
So the best analogy is like trying to see
a firefly just outside of a searchlight as
you're looking into the searchlight.
So he came up from this from pure thought.
But astronomers have been trying ever since
to find extrasolar planets. In that era, astronomy
was a high-risk profession.
He was put to death and tortured for these
thoughts, if you can believe it.
They seem very innocent today.
And it turns out that they were true.
But challenging the dogma at the time was
not encouraged.
So what have we learned since Bruno wrote
those words?
When I was in graduate school no planets had
been detected around other
stars.
We only knew the planets in our own solar
system.
And we can debate about whether Pluto's a
planet or not.
But certainly it's not a very rich data stream
to only know about the the planets in our
own solar system.
So astronomers have been working very hard
to find planets around other stars
and Keck Observatory has played a really big
role in this.
And the first way that planets have been found,
and the dominant way, we're now --
the first planets were found, you know, about
a dozen years ago around other stars.
And the way that it's done, primarily is as
-- as a planet goes around a star, the star
doesn't just sit absolutely constant in space.
Going back to physics 101 again, for every
action there's an equal and opposite reaction.
So say as Jupiter goes around our sun in a
very long arc, the sun doesn't stay precisely
still.
Of course, the sun is doing a little minuet
compared to Jupiter's long arc.
It does a very small orbit.
And the characteristic size of its orbit is
very similar to the diameter of the sun.
So it's just as Jupiter goes from one side
around, it's just
doing this little arc that goes around the
very center of the system,
the center of the mass of the sun/Jupiter
system.
So if we're looking at our sun from another
star, as Jupiter does this arc, we'd see very
small velocity changes in the sun's radio-velocity.
The velocity along the line of sight.
Conversely, we can look at other stars and
monitor their velocity.
If their velocity is dead constant, they probably
don't have planets around them.
But if we see periodic motions in their velocities,
it means that a planet is orbiting around,
around that star.
And that its gravitational influence has caused
the star to do a small orbit.
So this is an example of this kind of data.
The velocities that you have to be able to
measure for this are measured in meters per
second.
So you know you can walk a few meters per
So we're able, we're able with Keck Observatory
to measure velocities
to one meter per second on stars that are
typically 20 or 30 light
years away.
We have a very complex, very high dispersion
spectrograph
called high-res that takes the light of a
nearby star, it divides it
extremely finely.
And it gets the spectrum of the star.
And then we can cross-correlate that spectrum
to determine the doppler shift.
So this is the lowest mass planet found so
far by Keck.
The bigger the mass of the planet, the greater
the velocity change it will cause in its parent's
star.
So the most massive planets that are the closest
to their parent star are the easiest to detect,
because they have the largest gravitational
influence on the star.
We're most interested in things like planets
approaching earth mass. Well, we're interested
in all planets, of course, but the Holy Grail
would be to find an earth-mass planet around
a nearby star.
So this is as close as we've gotten.
It's a 22-solar mass planet.
And these are the velocities that when they're
phased together show that this planet is,
has an orbit around the star.
And this is the motion induced in the star
by the planet.
And instead of having a 365-day period like
the earth, a year on this planet is only 2.6
days.
So there's not much time to achieve your annual
goals on this planet. And we're constantly
pushing to lower our radio-velocity accuracy,
and -- to get to lower and lower mass planets.
And we're monitoring hundreds of planets.
This is the work of Jeff Marcy at UC Berkley
and Steve Vote at UC Santa Cruz, and all their
colleagues.
So there's about 400 planets that have been
found by this technique. More than half of
them have data from Keck Observatory that's
contributed to that.
So this is an artist's conception of what
that planetary system would look like.
I said the planet had a much shorter orbital
period so it's quite close in to the, to that
star.
And we can get more information than its mass
because we're very lucky in the case of this
planet.
Along our line of sight to this star, the
planet's orbit just happens to go right across
the face of the star.
So when it goes across the face of the star,
we can monitor the brightness of the star.
And as the planet goes across, the star just
gets ever-so-slightly fainter.
You know on the order of a percent or a half
a percent.
Because it's a darker surface that's replacing
the very hot surface on the star, so less
energy reaches the earth.
And we can time how long it's getting fainter
along the edge and that gives us the radius
of the planet.
So we have the mass of the planet from using
Newton's laws and the velocities.
And we have the radius of the planet, so that's
gives us a density. And we're able to get
a few other clues as to the properties of
the planet.
So we can start to talk about what the planets
are composed of because density changes dramatically
if you make something out of hydrogen and
helium gas versus making it out of iron.
So we can try different kind of density mixtures
of the types of the substances that are common
in our solar system and see if they're stable,
and see if they give the right radius.
And we believe that this Gliese 436b is made
of a small rocky core. And that its quote/unquote
mantel is made out of water
compressed into solid form.
And then it has a thin outer envelope of hydrogen
and helium gas.
So I think it's thrilling that we've gone
from the era where there was a big debate
about whether there are planets around other
stars,
to the point where we can talk about what
the planets are composed of
and really do kind of differential planetology
between the 400 planets that we know of.
And try to get to the fundamental questions
of what causes some solar systems to form
many planets, what causes Jupiter-mass planets
to be where they are in our solar system yet
there's some other solar systems where they're
much closer in.
And to understand the physics of what's going
on in this situation. The thing that limits
the Keck telescopes the most is the
atmosphere.
I told you we're above a lot of it but still
we have to deal with the remainder.
So we cope with this with adaptive optics
and Keck was the first large telescope to
have an adaptive optic system.
So this the schematic of how an adaptive optics
systems works to remove
the turbulence in the atmosphere which causes
that kind of twinkling
or shimmering of the stars.
The light comes into this system, and this
is a deformable mirror.
It can change its shape 2,000 times a second.
And this is a wavefront censor,
and it says what optical affects the atmosphere
has induced into the images of the star.
So you can see the star's jittery from the
atmospheric motion.
The atmospheres introduces defocus.
It introduces astigmatism, coma.
And here are you have imperfect wavefronts
coming in from the -- because the atmosphere
has distorted them.
The wavefront censor is like going to a optometrist.
It says you have this much astigmatism, this
much coma, and it rapidly changes the shape
of the mirror --
this mirror to exactly to exactly counteract
the optical aberrations that have been introduced.
So it's like getting a new prescription of
glasses that correct the distortions.
But you have to do this very fast.
The characteristic time in the atmosphere
is about 1000th or a 2000th of a second on
Mauna Kea.
We so need to understand every 2000th of a
second what aberrations have been introduced
by the atmosphere.
We then have to send signals to this deformable
mirror that has thousands of actuators on
its back and is about the size of say a dinner
plate.
Change the shape of that mirror, and then
repeat that cycle.
So maybe this is an area where we actually
have an interest in computer speed that maybe
approaches what you do at Google.
We need really fast processors for this kind
of a operation.
But the technology is absolutely revolutionary.
For the first time, large telescopes on earth
are largely freed of the distortions induced
by the atmosphere.
This has a lot of other applications as well.
You can imagine.
Just to being able to do better imaging through
the atmosphere period. But its absolutely
revolutionary for astronomy.
So we get a gain in spatial resolution using
the Keck telescopes with adaptive optics on
versus adaptive optics off of between 10 and
20, depending on the atmospheric conditions.
Typically, on a reasonable night on Mauna
Kea if we don't --
if we're not using adaptive optics the characteristic
size of an image is a half an arc second.
So 1/3,600th of a degree.
In California here maybe it would be one and
a half arc second, one arc
second.
We can get down to resolutions of .15 arc
second using adaptive optics on Keck.
That's better than the resolution you get
in the optical with Hubble space telescope.
So we're -- we're liberated at infrared wavelengths
where this works and going into red wavelengths
from the expense and complexity and risk of
launching telescopes above the earth's atmosphere.
We can build them on earth.
We can build them bigger.
We can build them cheaper.
They can become more adaptable over their
lifetime as new technologies come available.
And this is all thanks to adaptive optics.
So how -- what do we apply this to?
Let me give you a sense of the scientific
questions that are really --
been opened by adaptive optics.
So the center of our galaxy is an area very
different from, from where we live in the
galaxy.
It's 25,000 light years from earth so we're
--
where the earth and the sun are, we're kind
of out in the suburbs of the galaxy.
And the galactic center is very much Manhattan
or London, take your pick.
The -- just the density is a lot, is a lot
higher there.
But astronomers until they had adaptive optics
weren't really able to study it very well.
It's -- we're looking through the plane of
the galaxy, the plane of the
Milky Way to get to the galactic center.
There's a lot of absorption by dust so we
have to work in the infrared because astronomical
dust very much scatters and obscures optical
light.
But it's much less of a problem in the infrared.
And this is the inner -- this is a view of
the galactic center determined using the Keck
telescopes by a group led
by ANDRE GAST.
And you can see it gives a beautiful image.
This is the inner one arc second of the galaxy.
So it's a tiny area.
Without adaptive optics, this would just be
a blur.
Now we always knew this was a very interesting
place going way back, because one of the brightest
radio sources in the galaxy is at the galactic
center.
But there was very little known about the
stars right at the very center of the galaxy
until -- until adaptive optics on the Keck
telescope started probing this area at very
high resolution, led by Andre's group.
And then I'm going to show you what the motions
of these stars are like with adaptive optics,
this is a cartoon.
This is the year the data was taken, and it's
extrapolated somewhat beyond the present.
So each star moves along one of these orbits.
And this is the very center of the galaxy,
you can see.
This is a tiny area, only .1 arc seconds.
Now watch the stars as they go close to that,
to the very center on their elliptical orbit.
They're accelerated to huge, huge velocities
in accelerations as they go close in.
You can see them just whipping around there.
This will just -- this will just replay.
And this star here is -- they're all extremely
interesting at these velocities or this fast,
but the star that's most interesting is this
one here.
It goes very close to the center of our galaxy.
It goes within 90 times the distance between
the earth and the sun of the very center of
the galaxy.
Now, astronomers have always used the motions
of stars and Newton's laws to infer masses.
So we use the motions of the planets within
the solar system to get the mass of the sun.
So we can use those same kind of techniques
to use, you know, four sequels mass times
acceleration,
and the gravitational attraction law to get
what the mass is at the galactic center.
So within the orbit, within the closest approach
of this star, there is four million times
the mass of our sun.
So imagine that's all in stars.
This would be the brightest region of the
galaxy.
But you don't see anything there.
So -- and you really can't put four million
stars into that -- of the sun's size into
that kind of region.
So this is a black hole.
And you know, a discontinuity in space/time.
And we have other evidence with the Keck telescopes
that this is a super massive black hole.
We can see flashes of material as they get
accelerated and make their final orbit into
the black hole.
So this is the strongest gravity location
in our galaxy.
So it's a wonderful laboratory for physics
and astronomy.
And we didn't even know about it, you know,
before the Keck telescopes started looking
at this area of the sky with adaptive optics.
So it's probably the best place that we have
to test the theory of general relativity and
the strong gravity limit.
It's a wonderful place to understand the properties
of black holes. And after this discovery,
astronomers started looking at other large
galaxies to better understand the demographics
of black holes in other galaxies.
We can't get this exact kind of data, but
we can get more crude data that talks about
the motions of these stars from just a spectre
of the whole area.
And indeed, every respectable-size galaxy
has a super massive black hole in its center.
And in fact the larger the galaxy, the bigger
the black hole.
So there's galaxies that are much larger than
our galaxy, and
they have much larger black holes.
So it's raised some of the most, most interesting
questions.
In one of the most questions in astronomy
today.
How did something that's the size of the galaxy,
you know, the
whole huge galaxy, you know --
for example our star takes 250 million years
to orbit the galaxy, where some of these stars
take less than a
decade.
So we're talking about very, very different
scales.
How do these two scales know about each other
to have those things so
correlated?
Is this nature or is this nuture?
You know, did you start out with black holes
very early in the lifetime of the universe
and they were very important to pulling in
a lot of other material that became the galaxy?
Or did you have galaxy collisions so often
in the early universe that if you started
out with the small black hole at the center
of a galaxy it would just naturally get larger
and larger from all the merging activity that
happens?
So there's a lot of modelling and a lot of
other investigations going on to further explore
this question.
We've had another amazing discovery using
adaptive optics just in the last year.
In November 2008, this was announced.
I was telling you how we now know of 400 extrasolar
planets but we know
about them indirectly from this --
from looking at the motions of their, of their
parent star as the planets orbit.
But that's not a direct detection and astronomers
have wanted to get a direct detection of planets
for hundreds of years.
And so for the first time in late 2008, this
star, HR 8799, was imaged with Keck Observatory.
And the idea is to use adaptive optics to
make the image of the star as small as possible.
So that you're -- so that it's -- and then
try to block it out,
so that you've removed the source of glare,
and you can see the
planets around it much more accurately.
And we succeeded.
These are three planets around this star.
They're -- they're big planets.
You'd expect that we'd find the biggest ones
first, right?
They're the easiest to detect.
They're ten, ten, and seven times the mass
of Jupiter.
And there's in the outer parts of this exoplanetary
system.
So they're -- in terms of the separation between
the earth and the sun,
the earth/sun separation, they're 24, 37,
and 67 times further than the
earth is from our sun.
This is the work of KRISTA MARAW, BRUCE MACINTOSH
and colleagues.
But I think this is the beginning of a revolution
in exoplanet astronomy.
And I think we live at a very special time.
You know we're living when the first extrasolar
planets were found indirectly within the last
dozen years.
And we're also living at the time when it's
the first time we can take images of these.
Once you can take images of these, the next
logical step is to get spectra.
Once you get spectra, you can start to understand
what's in their atmospheres.
So play this -- take this technology and play
it forward with much greater capability.
Imagine being able to image an earth-mass
planet around another star. Let's say you
could do that.
That would be a huge achievement.
And then let's say you could take a spectrum
of an earth-mass planet. If you could take
a spectrum of our atmosphere, you'd be able
to detect that's there's quite a bit of oxygen
in our atmosphere.
You can't -- you don't have oxygen without
some sort of biological processes going on,
right?
Because it would all oxidize with everything
else, form things like rust, etc.
So you need something to replenish the oxygen.
You could probably detect a spectral feature
in our atmosphere.
It's called the red edge of chlorophyll.
So this is absolutely fundamental step on
the way to being able to probe for life in
the atmosphere, signs of life in the
atmospheres of other planets.
I think this is absolutely incredibly exciting.
We have another discovery of this sort that
was made in 2009 with Keck Observatory.
Methane was detected for the first time being
released in Mars in the northern summer.
This is a map of methane on Mars -- with methane
concentration, is here.
So this is -- this is incredibly exciting.
Let me show you how we do it.
You take a spectrum in the near infrared.
And there's methane lines in the near infrared.
It's kind of tricky cause there's methane
in the Earth's atmosphere. So again we make
use of this Doppler shift.
You find a time when Mars is moving relatively
rapidly along the line of sight with respect
to Earth.
So its spectral features are at a different
wavelength than the ones in earth's atmosphere.
This is the work of MIKE MAMA from NASA Goddard
Space Flight Center and colleagues.
And Keck has a very high precision, high resolution
near infrared
spectrograph.
That's one of the few instruments that has
the resolution to be able to detect methane
so well.
So here's Mars, and this is a slit.
The way we get spectra is we have to put a
slit, a one-dimensional slit, on an image.
So this goes across the disk of Mars.
And this is sort of a busy plot, please forgive
it.
But this shows the density of methane along
that disk in the northern summer and then
shows it in January 2006.
So the amount of methane has changed dramatically
over, over that time period.
So March 2003 was summer on Mars.
And when you go to look at where these emissions
of methane are from, they correspond to specific
geological regions on Mars that have
a lot of cratering and what looks like vents.
And so the hypothesis is since methane gets
broken down in Mars' atmosphere --
remember Mars doesn't have as protective a
layer as in its atmosphere as the Earth does,
that methane gets broken down from ultraviolet
radiation.
Mars doesn't have nearly as much surface gravity
as Earth does, so gases can escape.
So if you see something in the atmosphere
coming and going it has to be replenished.
So the hypothesis is that it's sort of like
hydrocarbon seeps on Earth. That there's vents
on the surface that go very deep, and when
the surface icing thaws in the summer, there's
out gassing.
And then when you go into winter period these
vents ice back up, so there's no more out
gassing.
So there's methane on Mars.
It's -- it's being replenished and the really
interesting thing is what's the source of
this methane?
We know there's geophysical ways to create
methane on Earth.
And we also know that there's biological ways
to create methane.
So the big question now is, is it possible
this methane is being created by biology on
Mars?
We know on Earth that there's microbes that
create methane that are
subterranean.
It's warm enough for them to exist because
the heated -- the heated crust from radioactivity.
So it's impossible to tell right now whether
it's, you know, geochemical or biological.
But we're, we're really attack --
it has been very exciting to our community
-- and we are really attacking this with
Keck.
The first thing we're trying to do is from
the spectra, we can also place limits so far
on how much ethane and formaldehyde and other
related molecules there are.
So we're going to push much harder on that.
In the time period coming up to try to --
cause you may be able to trace whether it's
geochemical or biological by the relative
amount of these other trace materials that
are produced.
But, we haven't used adaptive optics on this
yet.
And we've modified our adaptive optics system
so it will work at the wavelengths of methane
now.
So we're going to be able to get 10 to 20
times better resolution on where the methane
is being emitted.
So we're going to be able to understand where
the sources are to an
accuracy of about 50 kilometers.
So, you know, for us that's about the size
of Hawaii Island or even smaller.
So if you can localize it to an area like
that, NASA could put a spacecraft into there
someday.
And NASA is incredibly interested in this.
So stay tuned for what's -- what's the verdict
on whether the methane on Mars is biological
or geochemical.
It would be an amazing discovery if there's
really biological life on Mars.
And it would really, I think, change the way
that we envision ourselves here on Earth.
So what about the future?
This is an image of -- for our adaptive optics
system with Keck.
We actually launch a laser into the sky.
Originally what we'd have to do is do adaptive
optics near bright stars.
And that's what fed the wavefront censor but
bright stars aren't that much common, aren't
that common.
We want and need to be able to use adaptive
optics everywhere.
So we developed a laser technology that excites
the sodium atoms in
very upper atmosphere.
And that creates an artificial star, so we
can create an artificial beacon near any place
that we want to do adaptive optics on the
sky.
And so I've -- this is, this is a recent technical
highlight and enabled a lot.
And I'd like to talk a little bit about the
future in astronomy and at the Observatory.
We're continuing to push on adaptive optics.
The current systems only use one laser guide
star.
And we're designing a new system that uses
multiple laser guide stars, perhaps nine.
So that we can do tomography of the whole
of the turbulence, and the whole volume of
atmosphere above the telescope.
No one has done that yet.
That will effectively give as high resolution
images as you can possibly get out of a ten-meter
telescope.
And it will allow the full attainment of the
Keck telescopes.
It's going to allow a lot of new kinds of
science like watching planetary systems in
formation.
This is a simulation of a solar system forming,
and how we can see it in its early days.
This is a simulation of the galactic center.
This is Keck's current AO system.
And you can see it's kind of blobby in the
center, but we can break it better into individual
stars to understand those orbits with the
more sophisticated adaptive optics system.
So we're working very hard on that right now
and that's our number one technical priority.
So in wrapping up, what does the future look
like for ground-based astronomy and Keck Observatory?
The Observatory's been really productive in
terms of the scientific papers and scientific
results.
I hope I've given you a taste of that with
the work on understanding exoplanets and with
the amazing discoveries at the galactic center.
We'll continue to lead the Observatory's very
dynamic work.
Extremely committed to bringing on new technologies
and new instrumentation and adaptive optics
systems to allow the Observatory to do more
each year and discover more.
And some of you may have heard that we're
coming to the time period in astronomy where
people are starting to think about mirrors
that are even bigger than ten meters.
So what are we going to do with our ten meter
in that era?
We'll -- one way we'll shift is we'll enable
very large observing
programs.
You have to work really, really hard right
now, and have an
incredibly bright idea to get a few nights
in the telescope.
But we'll start to open it up so the people
with the best ideas will maybe be able to
get a month of telescope time.
And just create incredible data sets that
we can't even imagine today. There's some
very large imaging surveys the large synoptic
survey telescope, and Pan-Starrs are two projects
that are envisioned coming online.
And I understand maybe there's some Google
involvement on the large synoptic survey telescope.
But these systems will be able to map the
sky with a time scale of a
few nights.
So you can map the entire sky in a few nights,
then go
back and map it again and map it again and
see what's changing.
So look for stars that are varying, flashes
in the night that we wouldn't even be sensitive
to right now.
So that will be these amazing imaging data
sets.
We really want to optimize Keck to follow
up on those spectrascopically.
Because spectra really give you so much more
information.
It really gets much more the physics of what's
going on.
So we're going to be -- as these imaging surveys
come online, we're going to be optimizing
our instrumentation and our observing procedures
to really be able to leverage them really
well.
And to learn a lot more about time-sensitive
phenomena,
monitor time-sensitive phenomena that have
been found with the surveys spectroscopically.
These very large telescopes will be very expensive
and very project management intensive.
So they won't be able to take a lot of risk.
But we'll remain small and nimble so I see
us moving to higher risk, higher reward kind
of instrumentation and adaptive optics.
And being a real proving ground for those
kind of innovative instrumentation concepts.
That you can't afford to take the risk for
on the large telescopes, the
very large telescopes, that will migrate there
eventually.
But I have a prediction and that's that with
the adaptive optics now fully developed, our
community really using the telescopes and
partnering with us so well,
that the next ten years before these extremely
large telescopes come online, will be the
most productive in the
Observatory's lifetime.
And that will be the real legacy discoveries
that keep us in the astronomy books that are
published a hundred years
from now.
So I want to thank you all for coming today.
And thank you for your interest in astronomy.
And if any of you are out in Hawaii ever,
we'd love to show you the Observatory.
And it would be great to do more with Google
and all you Googlers. Thank you.
>>So we have time for a few questions.
I have a mike over here if you're able to
get in range.
>>I have a question about the adaptive optics
mirror that changes so
quickly.
What kind of material do you use to do that?
What's the mirror made of?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: It's -- I'm trying to think
of the exact substance.
But it's a -- it's a rubber -- I'll get real
technical.
It's a rubbery kind of substance that you
can place an aluminum coating over.
So it's -- you know, a very flexible ceramic.
And then there's piso-electric actuators behind
it that do the changes.
We're moving to new technologies there with
micromachine devices.
So that's the MAMS are really the future in
this area in terms of being able to get a
really high actuator cap.
>>Well, I was wondering if you could talk
more about the outreach that
Keck does to, you know --
like talks like this are awesome but do you,
you know, diversify this knowledge through
the community?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Yeah, great question.
You know we're really blessed that so many
people are interested in astronomy.
So it makes outreach really easier in astronomy,
I think, than in a lot of fields.
So we have monthly lectures at our headquarters,
where we have mostly
astronomers who are doing scientific research
give the lecture.
They're all podcast.
So if you go to our --
if you go to our Observatory website, KeckObservatory.org,
you can get at those podcasts.
We sometimes have lectures about new technical
things we're doing but it's mostly science
results.
We publish an e-magazine that comes out approximately
quarterly called Cosmic Matters.
We have astronomers and engineers who go into
the classrooms in Hawaii Island and communicate
with the the schoolchildren about the excitement
of astronomy.
And we participate in the visitor center on
Mauna Kea where people who are visiting Hawaii
or locals can go and look at the stars
at night on this amazing dark site.
I'm sure there's more but that's what comes
to mind immediately.
>>Can you tell us a little bit about how Keck
can be used to observe or
indirectly imply dark matter?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Yes.
Dark, dark matter is one of the -- one of
the most exciting areas in astronomy, I think.
And let me just say, just introduce dark matter
with a word.
Sometimes I create confusion by showing that
pie plot of the dark energy and the dark matter.
But the dark matter is where we just see the
gravitational signs of matter but we can't
explain it with stars or planets or other
baryonic matter.
So I'd say the laboratory we're doing the
most on dark matter,
and right now is, the Milky Way has a number
of small dwarf satellites. So these are galaxies
that have, you know, on the order of a million
solar masses.
A million to ten million.
And we can infer that from the motions of
the stars in the galaxy.
It turns out that these are some of the dark
matter richest objects that are known in the
universe.
And so we're -- we're really probing the numbers
of these, their dark
matter content, how the dark matter is distributed
within them.
Cause they give us the best information about
the clustering length of the dark matter.
Different forms of dark matter will cluster
on different scales.
And by, by having dark matter cluster on a
rather small physical scale, it rules out
a number of different types of dark matter,
different types of particles that could make
up the dark matter.
And we're very much involved in exploring,
with these dwarf
galaxies, the theory of a large galaxy formation.
The hierarchal structure formation theory
that says there were --
there was a lot of aggregation of dark matter
into these dwarf galaxy-sized chunks early
in the universe.
And that big galaxies formed by aggregating
or merging, you know, these small dark matter
clumps.
So we're testing that theory in great depth
around the Milky Way and around M-31.
>>Yeah, you're -- the animation of the galactic
center was really very
fascinating.
I believe I've read that in recent weeks and
months a couple of teens have think they've
observed a halo around the -- on the galactic
center.
And they were in the radio?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Yes, in the --
>>And in the gamma ray range.
And the more courageous astronomers are speculating,
looking over their shoulders --
gee, could this be the dark matter particles
colliding in the forming electron positron
clouds?
Anyway, it's really early on.
But is that -- is this the kind of thing that
infrared astronomy might be able to help with?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: It's a great question. I
heard --
>>You're seeing it at gamma rays and you're
seeing it at, you know,
microwaves.
TAFT ARMANDROFF: It seems very sensible that
that we should go and look
for this.
I have to admit I heard the discussion at
radio wavelengths.
And I simply haven't followed up with our
experts to understand what
we're doing about it.
So I'll get on that when I get home.
>>Hi, so when you -- when you're doing the
measuring, you're probably
feeding the light straight into a spectrometer,
right?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Yes.
>>So when you do CCDs, you had to do a lot
of calibration like flat
frames and bias and all that.
Do you have to do the same with spectroanalysis
or --
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Absolutely. And we call it
removing the instrumental
signature from the --
>>And so are you doing that in real time?
Because usually what I do is, you know, I
capture light, and then I capture the dark
frames.
I'm wondering how you do it in real time and
stack it in real time?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: I think we could improve
how we're doing.
But what we typically do is we take a lot
of the calibration data in the afternoon,
the biases and then -- and then we --
we initially start with creating the flats
by the data that have been taken so far during
the night or flats we've been able to take
during the afternoon.
So we try to, over the night do quick look
reduction.
But often the final data reduction product
has to wait until the next day,
when we can look at all of the data from the
night.
Particularly if it's very, very faint work,
and we need to make say a super flat from
the -- all the objects during the night with
the stars and galaxies removed.
>>So one additional question I had.
So the adaptive optics, right now there's
some products available for a couple of thousands
bucks for amateurs, right?
This is based on refraction and lens movement.
Adaptive optics elements, right?
Do you know anything about them or?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: I'm afraid I don't.
All of the products that we have are kind
of custom-made for the -- I mean, we buy the
deformable mirrors commercially.
And we're trying to get a source of commercial
lasers that's reliable. But I -- I don't know
almost anything about the off-the-shelf products
for amateurs.
I think it's really exciting, you know, that
that could be applied to other telescopes.
Kind of the democratization of astronomy,
with people being able to buy their own telescopes
and their own CCD cameras has been wonderful.
So I see the availability of adaptive optics
system, you know, to others than really major
observatories,
just a continuing of this democratization
and really cool.
>>So one final question, the optics themselves,
its design are RC
design, I believe. Right? The Keck? The ten-meter?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Yes.
>>I think we have time for one more question.
>>Thanks. That was inspirational.
You mentioned one thing early on which I'm
curious about.
What did you look at on the moon?
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Oh, yes.
The, you know, I was hoping that the data
analysis in this project would be done.
Cause earlier this fall we observed a NASA
experiment on the moon.
And let me back up just one step, we don't
usually observe the moon. So we had a NASA
had to allocate a special observing run where
we could just make sure we could track and
guide on the moon cause it's so -- you know,
it's such an unusual thing to observe with
a large telescope. So the -- NASA crashed
two rockets into the moon, with the idea that
it would bring up some of the subterranean
soil.
It's called the L Cross mission.
And Keck and another -- a number of observatories,
but I think we got some of the best data,
looked at the material right after this impact
with an infrared spectrograph tuned to the
wavelength region where water vapor would
be detected very well.
And the astronomers who took this data --
it's embargoed right now.
And they're working really hard on it to see
if water vapor was detected with Keck and
that same spectrograph that determined the
methane called the near speck spectrograph.
The -- and NASA's long rage interest in this
beyond science is if they were establish lunar
bases, you know,
could they have some apparatus that just went
a little into the soil and got the water.
So we're all eagerly awaiting the result.
And we'll, we'll disperse it through our,
through our networks.
By the way, it all --
I'd encourage you all to sign up on our website
to get news from the Observatory, when we
do have media releases about things like determining
whether there's water on the moon.
>>Well, Taft and our friends from Keck, thank
you very much for coming.
This is an amazing talk. Thank you.
TAFT ARMANDROFF: Thank you so much.